ces anonymes qui nous secours qui sont
ils
parmi eux parmi elles les infirmières à
guéret au centre hospitalier elles ont
une école en deux ans si tout va bien
elles seront diplômés d'état l'école a
été créée en 1963 à la suite d'un voeu
présenté par le docteur ferrand
président de la commission médicale
consultatif à cette époque l'école était
prévu pour 35 élèves
or il n'y en eu seulement que 23 et est
l'échec non aujourd'hui elles sont 105
il n'y a pas de garçons à cette école
cinq candidats infirmiers se sont
pourtant présentée au concours cette
année ils ont été éliminés
la profession d'infirmier reste
l'apanage des femmes elles sont donc
presque cinq fois plus nombreuses qu il
y a quatre ans pour monsieur bican
directeur du centre hospitalier
l'intérêt de cette école est à la fois
local et national
il ya un intérêt certain en ce sens que
les infirmières et qui sont formés à
l'école d'infirmière à l'airé vous
permettre d'avoir un effectif toujours
comme les infirmières à l'hôpital
et cette école n'a pas été créé
uniquement pour l'hôpital de guéret et
bien entendu elle ne participe à
l'échelon national à la formation du
personnel paramédical puisque d'abord le
département
nos élèves infirmières et qui sont reçus
du plan d'état peuvent aller travailler
dans les hôpitaux du département qui en
ont besoin et également dans certains
services publics les centres de
protection maternelle infantile du
dispensaire le centre de transfusion
sanguine et puis également l'échelon
national puisque beaucoup de nos jeunes
infirmières dont le travail est
également dans les hôpitaux de la région
parisienne ou dans les grands centres où
il a manqué à la suite de leurs deux ans
d'école certaines élèves restent hôtel
chez vous oui selon les besoins
tablissements ce n'est pas un grand
centre hospitalier nos besoins à
l'infirmière sont quand même assez
d'unités chaque année par exemple cette
année nous allons garder six ou sept
infirmières de la promotion qui va
sortir ou diplôme d'état qui se passe
actuellement à limoges et comme nous
avons une quarantaine d'élèves passent
leur diplôme d'état voyez la possibilité
que ça donne en temps aux établissements
au pouvoir recruter des infirmières
étaient ont été formés chez nous aguirre
l'enseignement se fait en deux parties
des cours théoriques par des médecins ou
des pharmaciens et puis les stages
hospitaliers 16 heures par semaine plus
quatre heures de soins
ces stages hospitaliers permettent aux
infirmières de mettre en pratique les
cours théoriques que comporte le
programme d études mais ils leur
apprennent à connaître la psychologie du
malade
cet être si sensible à porter cependant
de leur féminité
elles apprennent entre autres choses a
interprété une radioscopie et le centre
hospitalier de guéret dispose d'un
service important d'électroradiologie et
d'électrothérapie équipe et anas et
pouvant répondre aux examens les plus
délicats
le bloc opératoire où sont donnés les
cours d'assistance de chirurgie
fonctionne sous un air conditionné et
climatisés il est pourvu d'un matériel
très moderne avec un amplificateur de
brillance et un circuit intérieur de
télévision qui permet par exemple de
contrôler la réduction des fractures
être infirmière c'est certes une
vocation mais la vocation ne suffit pas
il faut répondre à un certain nombre de
critères d'adressent de technicité d'âge
aussi eh bien il faut avoir 17 ans et 8
mois au moins au 1er janvier qui suit
l'entrée à l'école d'autre part il faut
un niveau de culture générale valable
c'est à dire que pratiquement le
baccalauréat dispense examen d'entrée 7
qui ne sont pas titulaires du
baccalauréat doit obligatoirement subir
un examen d'entrée qui est tout de même
le niveau de première
la pédiatrie et la spécialité que
préfère généralement les élèves
infirmières qui apprennent à donner le
biberon même à l'intérieur d'une
couveuse
une femme est toujours maire
les règles à respecter sont avant tout
celles de l'hygiène l'instinct maternel
et dans le bébé s'endort bercé par la
jeune élève
elle s'est aussi les distraire
elle s'est aussi les consoler voilà
vraiment une profession féminine en 63
qu on les colle a débuté il y avait 23
élèves cette année va y en avoir 120
à quoi attribuez vous ce succès et bien
d'une part un débouché certain pour les
élèves pour les infirmières
donc pour les jeunes creusoise et
d'autre part au succès de l'école
simplement une infirmière diplômée n'a
pas de problème d'emploi
oh non il n'y a pas de problème n'en
voir so lu ment pas